hey guys this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so very quickly for
those who are watching my video for the
first time
this is youtube so i need to introduce
myself i'm a professional trader
and i decided to make some youtube
videos to talk about
technical analysis which is reading the
charts but also reading the flows like
the option market
the short interest to understand the all
different mechanisms like the gamma
squeeze
or the short squeeze and in this video i
want to make an update on the option
market and all this
short shares information on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so like i did for mc
first i just show you quickly my chart
i'm bullish i think we have a target of
800
once again i'm not saying this is the
ceiling i'm just
saying that if we go there we gonna find
some selling pressure
so all the technicals are telling me we
are bullish
even if like i'm missing the volumes but
we are in a bullish development for you
know quite a long time and
you know i'm expecting this price action
to keep going higher but
what is interesting to look at is the
option market so let's have a look all
right guys
so like i did for amc i just you know
i'm not gonna explain everything here
what is important is to check the open
interest so here we have
total 11 million equivalent shares so
you have it on every strike every
maturity i'm just showing you guys that
you know
i really did it you know it's not like i
just take
some other videos or whatever and give
you the same information this is my
information you're not gonna find it
anywhere else
this is what i did and you know i just
use some formulas to come up not only
with the
option open interest that is interesting
but not sufficient guys
you need to use the delta and go check
my video the video i did
on amc where i explained this into
details here i'm just gonna go quicker
but i think it's very interesting for
you guys to get a quick reminder about
what the delta means
the delta is the probability of
finishing for call option in the money
so it's for example the probability to
trade above let's take the 800 strike
because this is the most interesting one
and look at the very big open interest
two million shares equivalents so the
probability of trading
above 800 in for example may
is 0 but the probability of training
above the 800 level we're gonna check
the july october and june
so what's the probability to finish at
800. so for june
you can see so it's this one it's eight
percent so you have eight percent
chance to finish above the 800 level
and if you do the same for july it is 18
and if you do the same for september it
is 42
so guys there are not many places where
you can find
what the market is pricing what is the
probability
about finishing above this level and
once again to do that
i only compute the delta so the
volatility is here
so the formula is here guys you can do
it yourself you're going to find the
same number
as me if you have troubles just put it
in the comment i'm going to help you
to understand what you need guys to do
you
just apply this formula which is here s
is the spot
k is the strike sigma is the volatility
t is the maturity
t needs to be in years and then you use
the normal distance formula applied to
d1 and n of d1 is the delta so
first information 40 chance to finish
above 800 in
september breaking news then second
information i want to show you guys
is actually how this synthetic short
which is right now
six percent because we are all the delta
is not equal to one
so the maximum synthetic shot for now is
21
so this is the data you're gonna see
everywhere but my data you cannot see
everywhere because you need to compute
the delta and most of people don't even
know what it is
so we are right now at six percent of
synthetic short
right all the other numbers that you see
on this are unfortunately
wrong and we can go up to 21
and what i want to show you guys is
where it's coming from and as you can
see
it is mostly coming from the 800 strike
even when we are trading at 180 because
the volatility is high
so these options have actually a lot of
data you can see that
80 million usd uh so this is national is
sitting at this level
so this is the green curve is the
position is almost the biggest one so
you have more
uh national sitting at the 200 strike
but whatever and look what happens if
this goes higher this is the gamma
we're going to converge the delta is
going to converge to 1 because the
probability of finishing above
a strike for a spot that is going higher
is increasing
and this is converging to 21 and if we
go higher of course
the 800 strike is the one that is going
to get the most exposure
so i just showed you guys that right now
we can go to
21 22 is the same as the maximum
for now we are at six percent
so if gamestop goes higher market makers
would have no other choice than buying
shares in the market and this is what
is gamma squeeze when all the market
makers are forced to buy shares
because they have a short position
against a retail investor which exposure
is increasing
with the spot going higher this is the
delta
now my target is 800 i'm not saying is
the maximum we're gonna see on gamestop
i'm just telling you that this is a
reasonable target that i think might
happen
so i'm gonna show you guys some cool
option
strategies that you can use because once
again
once you get all this information what
you need to do
what professionals do is that you sell
the high volatility
strikes and you buy the lower volatility
strikes because this is
how things are supposed to work you are
selling what everybody is buying
and then you are on the right side in
expected gains of course
but you won't be selling that hundred
strike if you don't buy anything else
so let me just show you for example if
you have let's say 100 shares
your piano profile is like this for
example if gamestop goes to 100
you can lose 7000 us dollars all right
so just remember this because this is
something that is possible
and this is your loss if we go there
now how much money you can make if you
go to 800
you can make 60 000 us dollars let me
show you another strategy
same as i did for amc that is actually
making
the same amount of money but for a lower
risk
you can buy a cold spread like i said
you buy
this strike the 550 i calibrated those
strikes
to actually get something that is not
too expensive and
you sell this one so if you only buy the
550 strike call
it's going to cost you 1 000 us dollars
all right and
you can make if we go to 130 000 us
dollars
so it's the same money as if you had 50
shares all right
let's imagine you have 50 shares so you
can make the same
amount of money roughly 30 000 us
dollars but 50 shares it can cost you
if we go to 100 3 000 us dollars and if
we go below even more
here if you sell your shares and you buy
call options you can buy only one option
which is as a multiplier it can make 100
shares
you make the same money at the 30 000
level of course you make
nothing if we go to 550 so this is the
problem of the strategy
but you have a very limited risk on the
downside
and the smart strategy that
professionals
are doing i mean the clients that i have
uh you know like to do this kind of
strategies it's because it's lowering
your price you're selling the 800 strike
call
because it is the one that is the most
expensive
and in terms of volatility of course the
price is
half the price of the 550 strike
so now you only spend 500 us dollars
and you have the same money on the 800
strike
so you spend 450 and you can make 25 000
us
dollars and if you are fine with
spending actually a bit more because
you're gonna tell me but
you know i don't care about selling the
800 strike you know i'm okay to lose 1
000.
so you're going to tell me i prefer to
have this so i make more money
if we go above 800 but then i'm gonna
tell you
look what is even smarter is to sell
this one so now
it costs only 500 us dollars 450
and if you're fine with spending double
you just double it right
and so you spend the same 900 us dollars
this is the money you can
lose added the premium so now you can
lose 900 us dollars
but if we go to the 800 strike
you can make 50 000 us dollars guys all
right
so you can choose whatever you want but
i'm telling you that this kind of
strategies is the strategies
that professionals would do right
selling
the very expensive strikes that
everybody is buying and buying those
that are before where the volatility is
lower and once again you can tell me
that
you you prefer to keep your shares which
i can understand but
you just you know it's interesting i
think to see that you have all the
strategies they can make
much more money on the upside and that
you know have a very
limited downside risk if you think uh
short squeeze
is to happen and we can see that you
know
this short squeeze happened for example
in january and
right now the dtc is one to two
depending if you use
the weekly volume or if you use the
monthly volume all right
so it can happen again all right we can
see that the short interest is not
increasing for now it's increasing on
amc
but if you believe that this quiz will
eventually happen
but for now as you can see guys we are
in the green area for all the parameters
i'm checking
so the squeeze is to me not coming very
very soon
but still gamestop can go higher and
like i said
we can have the game as quiz so i'm
going to keep an eye on all this data
that is here because this number is very
huge and like i said the 800 strike
is very very animated you have a lot of
open interest
there so if you believe this can happen
guys you know
i just gave you a strategy that has a
very low risk
for uh insane profit on the upside
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys